now this debate is virtually sold out
750 tickets sold I think there were a
hundred more on the waiting list which
is a tribute both to our subject matter
the passions that the lady arouses still
on all sides and of course to the very
high quality of our speakers we have for
the motion Lord bel Charles Moore and
Sir John not and against the motion
Billy Bragg Sir Peregrine were stone and
Dan Abbott I'm going to introduce them
at somewhat greater length individually
before they speak but for the moment
let's press on with the debate and hear
what they have to say first of all we
have Charles MA now Charles has spent a
lifetime in journalism he began working
for The Spectator became its editor and
then a weekly columnist for the Daily
Express the deputy editor of The
Telegraph becoming eventually the editor
of The Sunday Telegraph a position he
held until 1995 when he became editor of
The Daily Telegraph he is currently
group consulting editor and columnist of
The Daily Telegraph he's a columnist for
The Spectator and perhaps most
importantly which is the reason he is
the real reason he is here tonight he is
the authorized biographer of Margaret
Thatcher and he was talking just just
before we came in here about the
difference between between being the
official biographer and the authorized
biographer the official biographer means
that it is government commissioned which
is what he is definitely not doing the
authorized biographer means that he has
got unfettered access to all her papers
and can write whatever he wishes to
write I think he said he's got another
five years work to do on this but he
cannot publish the book until after Lady
Thatcher has passed away which was
something that I didn't know and I'm
sure it would be interesting to all of
you but he's already done a copious
amount of work on this book so to kick
off the debate for the motion suggesting
that Maggie Thatcher say Britain please
welcome Charles Moore
[Applause]
[Applause]
Thank You mr. Jim could I borrow a watch
to says not to exceed I don't think
generous Act bicep egrant um thank you a
famous story who wouldn't much have
agreed with Margaret Thatcher didn't ra
Butler famously described the politics
is the art of the possible and that's
obviously true but I think it's also a
rather self-limiting idea about politics
because the idea of what's possible
constantly narrows in upon itself and it
leads civil servants who know that you
believe in the art of the possible to
say sorry minister that's not possible
it can't be done and gradually there's
less and less that a minister can do I
want to argue that for Margaret Thatcher
politics was in a sense the art of the
impossible or Easter seemingly
impossible and that's why she made such
a difference that's why she did save
Britain now to understand that you need
to go back to the 1970s Ted Heath went
to the country prematurely because of
the miners strike in February 1974 and
he asked who governs Britain which was
the question on everybody's minds but a
thoroughly stupid question for a
government to ask and the result was
really that the electric wave gave no
clear answer and we then had five years
of virtually sometimes minority labor
government what had happened essentially
is that the Tories had confronted union
power and had failed and labor under Jim
Callaghan in particular had appeased
union power and after the winter of
discontent had also failed and I think
we must remember in all of this debate
that people really did think that
Britain had become uncover Noble and
that economic recovery was impossible
Ted Heath's cabinet secretary William
Armstrong said that the the job of the
civil services he saw it was the quote
orderly management of decline that was
the overriding view of what the future
held for this country which really means
very little future at all and I think
Margaret Thatcher never ever believed
that and in studying her early papers
and speeches and
I find this even even when she's a
student when she's a candidate in
Dartford in 1950-51 the idea is always
there that Britain has a huge capacity
to be strong and free prosperous and
respected it's an astonishingly
optimistic and astonishingly ambitious
idea and I don't know I happen to be
watching the television on the day when
the task force set sail for the
Falklands and I remember her sitting
there and said I'm going to quote Queen
Victoria she said the possibility of
failure does not exist not true of
course but when you say that it becomes
more true than if you don't
once we were staying in in a friend's
house in the country a few years ago and
Margaret Thatcher was there and our son
who was seven at the time suddenly came
into the room and I didn't think he knew
who mrs. Thatcher was but he embarrassed
me because he said me she sat down in
such a sort of pretend to be a grown-up
and he said did you like being Prime
Minister and she said we had the chance
to do important things for our country
so yes we enjoyed it very much and so um
so so William said oh did you pass any
good laws then and she said yes we did
we made Britain strong in defence we
reduced the power of the trade units and
we cut taxes so that if people can keep
more of what they earn they earn more at
this point Williams interview went
rather awry because he said oh did you
get very rich then when you were Primus
but but no we didn't have to Weaver but
but I thought first of all it was very
good that she immediately answered the
question properly and treated him as if
he were Robin day rather than a young
idiot em and secondly I think that what
she said was fundamentally true those
three things and the hard factual
consequences of that can to some extent
be quantified an income tax rate which
was 33 percent standard rate when she
began and is 22 now inflation which was
17.2% when she began and his 2.6 percent
today in 1979 date working days lost two
strikes
twenty-nine million
and 16,000 today 236,000 sorry 1997
236,000 and growth in 1979 Germany's
growth rate 4.5 percent Britain's naught
point 5 percent today Germany minus 0.1
percent Britain 2.7 percent and UK
unemployment today is half the EU
average these are statistical ways of
expressing a huge outpouring of
possibilities for the British people
that have come about as a result of what
Margaret Thatcher did the setting up the
capacity to set up your own business
the much greater opportunity and
increase in owning your own home much
greater chance of owning shares often
through privatization having democratic
power in your trade union in a way which
was actually forbidden by law in the
1970s and having in general a far
greater opportunity to choose your way
of life and make of it what you will and
a process which I think Tony Blair's
to some extent understood and certainly
benefited from in which success builds
on success that the vicious circle for
which we suffered in the 70s is reversed
and a virtuous circle is created we got
there first we realized we had to move
from manufacturing to services we
encountered and dealt with problems
which Germany is encountering and trying
to deal with less successfully today but
the other thing about this is what
happens in the whole world as a result
of this the huge possibilities for
Britain that opened up as a result of
what Margaret Thatcher did the Falklands
War was in some respects ik total
absurdity in that the the place in
question was so small the number of
people and so far away the number of
people involved so small but the
principle was not the principle that
aggression had to be defeated and it did
show the whole world which people did
not believe at the time that democracy
can assert political and military will
against aggression and Margaret Thatcher
did this
remember at the beginning against her
greatest ally America who were very very
dubious about it against huge numbers of
doubters at home against a great deal of
international opposition and I do
believe and it was said by Willie
Whitelaw on the day we won that she was
the only person who could conceivably
have had the will to do that and once
you've asserted your strength you then
create a much greater capacity to do
other things than just asserted and a
thing that's not so much noticed about
Margaret Thatcher is her capacity to
make peace as well as her capacity to
make war she's thought of rightly as a
highly a combative person but if you
look at the history of the Cold War I
think it will show that having made
ready tough decisions about the siting
of cruise missiles in this country and
deliberately going against the
conventional wisdom of the Foreign
Office and helping dissidents in Eastern
Europe seeing people like souls in it's
in that the Iron Lady then felt when she
deceived something that she could soften
she thought she was the first in Europe
who spotted Gorbachev she was the first
to have him to visit she was the first
who told Ronald Reagan that he should
see Gorbachev Gorbachev subsequently
became a Soviet leader and mrs. Thatcher
drove a process of tough-minded
deterrent which had happy results her
period in power began with the Soviet
invasion of Afghanistan and ended after
the collapse of the Berlin Wall
there are huge omissions of course and
huge problems I'll leave my opponents to
to deal with all of those but I just
want to end by bringing something else
together I want to think about the
impact that one person and especially
one woman can have nobody could dream of
arguing that John Major or Jim Callahan
or or perhaps even Tony bear they will
see whether Diane wants to argue this
night saved Britain but Margaret
Thatcher is different there is a way and
it is to do with her sex and her
character in which she embodies
expresses and magnifies certain
characteristics of the nation
and rather as Elizabeth the first did in
her speech at Tilbury early in her
Premiership she went to one of those
self congratulatory dinners of a
think-tank and she was asked to speak
she was very bored they've been speaking
for ages she got up and she said I've
just listened to seven speeches by men
and I'd like to say the [ __ ] make row
that the hen lays the eggs
[Applause]
Charles thank you very much indeed and
our next speaker is a Paragon worst on
who was lead writer and foreign
correspondent for The Times in the early
part of his career just after the war
he was on the editorial staff of the
daily and the sunday telegraph for many
years and eventually became editor of
The Sunday Telegraph books he has
written include the socialist myth and
in defense of aristocracy so what is he
doing
opposing tonight's motion let's find out
so Paragon Westall I asked myself what
am i doing because of course in many
ways I found myself in complete
agreement with everything the Charles
Moore has said in defense of when praise
of mrs. Thatcher because of course it
was very much the tune that I myself
sang with total conviction during the
saturate era and it's perfectly
justified to but what I would like to
say tonight is something different
because we are living in the post
saturate era and it's possible for a
star to reflect on those years I was a
great fan of hers and indeed a
beneficiary
she gave me my knighthood and so on and
therefore in a way I feel slightly
treacherous
in doing what I'm doing tonight but I
feel myself in looking at her legacy
which I regard as having been
spectacularly and horribly destructive
from us that made this country elaborate
place that I have really no honest
alternative mrs. T was absolutely right
to want to reduce the excessive power of
the trade unions but the trouble was
that the ugly passion she released
duties went on to destroy much else
besides including of course the ill
Labor Party but I expect my colleagues
on this side will will dwell on that but
I as well as of course the destruction
of the old Labor Party there was the to
my mind perhaps more important
destruction the destruction of the old
Conservative Party and she destroyed
much else besides in fact in my view
living here as we do in the 21st century
much else
what made Britain such a lovable place
to be but not content with having tref
trashed the great tradition of working
class solidarity and comradeship a truly
precious national asset she went on to
do the same for the upper-class
tradition of public service and
paternalism also in my view a very
precious national assets ladies and
gentlemen it was a Faustian pact for the
only way she could hope to overwhelm
trade union militancy of a period a
militancy which I suspect was it its
last gasp
was to release the even uglier passions
of f6 man and their ugliness is by no
means at its last gasp the only way she
could knock the stuffing out of Arthur
Scargill was to put it into Rupert
Murdoch
another bad bargain in my judgment very
much a case of out of the frying pan
into the fire
ladies and gentlemen with a horrible
period despite the gloss that that
Charles has put upon it the language IRA
Paul tells it all I remember a close
aide of mrs. Sarah one of one of her
loyalists and most supportive aide
saying to me not only would I die for
mrs. Thatcher but I would kill for the
lady as well this was profoundly a
profoundly unning leash period in
British politics and the fact that
during this period the phrase do-good
ism should have become a dirty word and
that the public spirited but endless
side of the Tory party should have been
dismissed contemptuously as the wets
this was all a side of terrorism that I
think doesn't do the lady any credit
increasingly during this prep period I
felt that the language of politics was a
very uh Ning glish one something that I
had never heard in my own experience
before what she wrought was nothing less
than the bourgeois revolution very
little was left undone trashed the
professions the BBC the universities the
churches and even Charles's old
newspaper and my old newspaper The Daily
Telegraph
IRA's on margaret's what's that this
symbol of respectable England the organ
that bank managers carried under their
arm where they wanted to be to impress
their possible clients of their
respectability was the Daily Telegraph
people had eaten their house rather like
an earlier generation had the Bible to
show not just that they were that they
were predicted that they were
respectable people but they were
aspiring to be it was a symbol of
respectable aspiration and on her watch
characteristically because the same
thing happens at the times and if
whatever she her influence else way
somebody took over with her blessing and
as we now know after 15 years a
proprietorship has brought the paper
into disgrace through having his hand in
the till yes it was a bourgeois
revolution it was probably in his
consequent in in its effects as profound
as the bourgeois revolution that took
place in France 200 years earlier and
just as the bourgeois Revolution which
took place in France 200 years earlier
lift the body politic of France
sick sick unto death and he still never
recovered from that I suspect and I feel
deeply that the consequences of the
Tetra right revolution which we are now
experiencing may have the same effect
not on the economy
god knows no could be nobody can ever
deny her enormous ly valuable role in in
improving that but on the body politic
ladies and gentlemen with the end of
communism the next great challenge in my
judgment when my guess work far more
seriously far more serious than the
battle against or the challenge of
terrorism is going to be the global
consequences of corporate greed now in
my view
in my view Britain was uniquely well
qualified to take a leading part in this
all-important new challenge if at all it
was uniquely suited to do so because of
its the continuities of its history it
had in all classes traditions intuitions
sensibilities which went back to the pre
capitols age we record we have this
unique record of continuity and I'm
afraid that is a legacy which she has
squandered of course she meant well she
meant to restore the values of her
father
alderman Roberts but ladies and
gentlemen it's a very very sad and
tragic story but it seems to me that
about our legacy is to leave a country
fit or fit not so much for her father
with his Victorian virtues but her son
and this is a very and this is and this
is the burden of my comments it is that
the consequences of mrs. Thatcher which
which is the one you should bear in mind
I don't disagree at all with Charles he
was right but we're now beginning to see
the consequences and it's the
consequences I beg of you to consider
when you come to vote tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
Peregrin thank you very much indeed for
that interesting and unusual angle that
you've taken on the motion we're now
going to hear from Lord Bell in favor of
the motion Lord Bell rode shotgun to
Maggie Thatcher insofar as anyone could
do that
during her rise to power and through her
years as Prime Minister
he was reputed to offer her advice ideas
on and lateral thinking on a level which
he received from few others not
surprisingly he went on to found and
become chairman of the chyme group of
companies offering what else
high-quality public relations and
business advice to organisations across
Britain and around the world and those
people who run them from big
corporations to governments as a trusted
lieutenant he had an unrivaled view of
the Thatcher years from the inside so he
is not surprisingly going to speak for
the motion Lord Bell good evening I have
a disadvantage in that most of what I
was going to say Charles has already
said that I have one advantage which is
that I went last night to have a drink
with Baroness Thatcher I told her that
this debate was taking place and I can't
resist telling you this she asked me who
was on the panel and of so Peregrine's
she said it's silly Perry
I did ask her if she would mind
recording for me a couple of minutes of
how she saved Britain but she refused to
and said that I'd have to make it up so
I'm going to it does it does strike me
actually that having had a drink with
her last night I was reminded of just
how feisty she can be and I should tell
you all for those of you who care she is
in remarkably good Nick and not a
drunken old fool as people like to
project her in the press she is very
concerned about her son who incidentally
rather like Conrad Black has not yet
been found guilty of anything and I
think the word alleged would be slipped
in there somewhere
mark is in South Africa and having a
difficult time his mother is somewhat
concerned about it as I think any mother
would be about her son in such problems
and that was the essence of our
conversation last night what so I
thought today was rather a striking day
to be discussing this since it's only
yesterday that Lord Hansen died who was
one of the great standard bearers of
Margaret's economic revolution if I can
put it in those terms he I don't think
qualifies for the Essex title that Perry
handed on those people who tried to
succeed for themselves but he was
somebody who who benefited hugely from
the way that she changed the attitude
that we had towards the economy of
Britain I think to understand this
debate which is actually not about what
legacy did she leave or is she did she
manage not to solve some of the problems
that haven't yet happened which I
sometimes people are rather prone to
discussing the essence of this debate is
whether or not she saved Britain and I
think in order to understand that you
have to cast her own mind back to the
70s and how Britain was when she became
prime minister in 1979 I think if you
consider that the Prime Minister had to
go to the International Monetary Fund to
borrow money in order to keep Britain
going or if you put it in your own
domestic circumstances having spent all
the wealth that you have you then have
to go to the bank to extend an overdraft
and the conditions of the overdraft are
somewhat difficult for you as the IMF
wherever they're handed out if you
consider that the winter of discontent
was a time at which people were
basically unable to bury their dead
relatives and where people were
terrorized in the streets from entering
factories and entering offices and
schools where the vast majority of the
workers of the employed union member
workers in Britain were on strike for no
good reason that anybody could
understand when you consider that she
entered office and honored the
commitments of the clegg Commission on
public sector pay which caused her great
difficulty in terms of the economic
things that she wanted to do and when
you consider and I might if I if I'm
allowed to quote something from her book
which I brought with me in case anybody
really upset some because actually he
didn't with it she looked at when she
came to look at the state of the economy
she discussed it in cabinet as she
reports in her book and it's really
where the wets and drys first emerged
the the issue that people were talking
about was what to do about the economy
people knew that there were things that
should be done but they were concerned
that they should that they couldn't and
she faced this extremely difficult I'm
shuffling my papers around as I've
forgotten why I wrote this but she she
wanted to change the way that we ran the
economy she wanted to cut taxes she
wanted to reduce public expenditure she
wanted to make industry not dependent on
the state but to spending but dependent
on its successes it was the view at the
time that she took office partly caused
by the collect Commission partly caused
by the IMF alone and partly caused by
the difficulties that existed in the
economy it was a view that she should
cut taxes and yet the problem was that
revenue was threatening to decline how
could you cut taxes and see less revenue
coming along it was a view that she
should cut public expenditure but the
public sector was the only place
creating jobs the private sector was too
weak to do so and she wanted to reduce
industry's dependence on the state by
removing state subsidies and making
industry stand on its own two feet which
again was something that she
passionately believed in
the debates in cabinet was pretty much
along the lines that you couldn't do any
of those things because they would have
a devastating effect she said in her
book we were traveling down the down
escalator and in order to escape from it
we had to run up it and we had to run up
it extremely fast my phone has gone off
to something yes probably is her
now Billy I can assure you should never
listen to anything I said so I doubt if
she would ring she said we were
traveling down the down escalator and it
was essential that we ran very fast to
get up to the top of it so she did
exactly the opposite of what everybody
was saying should be done she did can
taxes she did reduce public expenditure
she did remove subsidies from industry
and she did make the private sector
stand on its own two feet she tackled
the problem of the of the imbalance of
power that the unions had over the
workforce and over the ordinary people
of Britain she would say to me quite
often that quoting - not quite sure from
where I believe in a country where all
may grow strong but none at the expense
of each other
that was a very difficult policy for her
to carry through she did make Britain a
great country again she made it hold its
head up in the face of an environment
where I think if you cast your mind back
to the 70s much of the writing that was
going on at the time was predicting that
we should happily settle in the second
or third division stop trying to be a
great nation and be important in world
affairs and accept our fate or in fact
our destiny the truth is that she
accepted none of those things as Charles
so eloquently said but she began her
term of office with this phrase the
forces of error doubt and despair was so
firmly entrenched in British society as
the winter of discontent had just
powerfully Illustrated that overcoming
them would not be possible without some
measure of discord and it is of course
the discord that Peregrine's touches on
as being he found rather offensive and
vulgar but she recognized that we were
not going to shake ourselves out of the
situation that we were in unless we
allowed ourselves to have some discord
for people to disagree with each other
for the wets to be different to the drys
for the people who thought that their
job was to protect those people and who
were poor and who a week would sometimes
misunderstand some of the things that
she did although I can assure you from
my own personal experience she only ever
wanted to help those people
she also recognized politically that we
were entering a new era I think it was
JK Galbraith who when asked to define
the middle classes said that the middle
classes were functionaries without
capital
who Knut like stand against the ear
rising tide of proletarianization and
that was a force that she could
recognize was coming but I think in my
view history will reflect that Margaret
Thatcher saved Britain when it was at a
crossroads a crossroads of giving
Britain a sense of identity or allowing
us to backside into geopolitical
oblivion a crossroads of empowering
British people by being tough on the
unions and reducing dependence on
welfare or continuing the debilitating
dependency on a state unable to respond
financially a crossroads of economics
which would reduce taxes and create jobs
or one which would undoubtedly continue
the nation's financial decline and
finally perhaps most importantly a
crossroads which meant standing shoulder
to shoulder with America to defeat once
and for all the awful political and
economic system that was communism in
the Soviet Union or to sneak out the
back door and our responsibilities to
our country and the rest of the world I
think that she did all those things and
I think that she left Britain in a much
better condition than when she took it I
think she saved the country from the
kind of disasters that were being
accepted by people as the norm she left
us a freer country a prouder country and
a more successful country she did in my
view save Britain she also had a hand in
saving the world I will leave you one
last story which I and Astoria and note
I got when she left office it was a
handwritten note from John BIRT who was
then the director-general the BBC and
who is now Lord Burt and in the Downing
Street modernization unit in one of Tony
Blair's most trusted advisors he was the
director of the BBC which I should
remind you Dennis would frequently
described as a nest of pinkos in fact I
remember that John Bird also threw a
dinner for her when she left office and
we went along to this to this dinner and
I went with them and Peter Jay was
amongst the hosts and Dennis walked up
to him and said I'm amazed at what you
do now Peters wonderful of things you
achieve what kind of staff do you have
and he said um just one researcher he
said we whitewall that
stuff with just one researcher and Peter
J Sedna I think you're confusing me so
Dennis you're thinking when I was the
economics editor at The Times I'm now
the economics editor of the BBC and
Dennis replied never watch it John wrote
in this rather sweet note to me the
following sentence the sad thing about
her departure is that all those people
who wish to make something of themselves
will now have to try that much harder I
urge you to support the motion
[Applause]
[Music]
but well thank you very much and we now
come to the great Billy Bragg recently
described by The Times newspaper as a
national treasure in the two decades of
his career he has made an indelible mark
on the conscience of British music
becoming perhaps in a store word
guardian of the radical dissenting
tradition that goes back over centuries
of this country's history he is here
tonight as an anti Thatcher Crusader
very well known one after seeing how the
Conservative government of Margaret
Thatcher was changing the fabric of
British society and as he saw at
decimating the mining communities his
songs became more overtly political he
became a fixture at political rallies
and benefits particularly during the
1984 miners strike with his strident
songs of political solidarity and those
songs have taken his albums many times
into the UK top 20 his song speak of
freedom and the need for social change
he is known to some of his fans as the
bard
of barking we shall see whether he lives
up to that title tonight Billy
over to you goodie bag thank you very
much I have to tell you that barking of
which I'm a bard is as a town in Essex
Perry and I I do resemble that remark
about Essex man I think we were we were
much maligned in the 1980s but I do find
myself a rather strange situation for me
to be on the platform here with wits of
Peregrine but I find myself listening to
the things he said and and an
understanding precisely where where he's
coming from
the question I think about Margaret
Thatcher did she say Britain is exactly
the way that that perry framed it she
was some would say that the the greatest
post-war conservative prime minister but
what did she actually conserve let's
think about the things that some that
she attacked our institutions
local government the Greater London
Council she got rid of Ken Livingstone
Yeah right
in the end what Ken Livingstone stood
for democratically appealed to Londoners
mrs. Thatcher couldn't abolish that it's
impossible to do that at the other end
of the spectrum she took our fragile
Constitution which has developed over a
thousand years of history and she
Bentley our shape in order to to express
her will to do what she wanted to do and
what did that do it left our
Constitution open to those of us who
want to reform it because people saw how
fragile and how transparent it actually
was do you think the House of Lords
would be on the agenda abolition of the
hereditary zhh would have happened were
not Margaret Thatcher using him time and
time again getting the backwoodsmen in
to put through her policies and also in
Scotland and Wales the the matter of the
Union the integrity of the United
Kingdom was brought asunder by Margaret
Thatcher when she decided that the Scots
who wouldn't vote for her they were then
they were not us so she cast them out
the Scottish Nationalist Party were able
to to find a revival of nationalist
spirit and the end result was a Scottish
Parliament a Welsh Parliament possibly
one day even an English Parliament if if
this does happen I feel that the the
first little tear that began to to break
the United Kingdom part will have been
done by Margaret Thatcher the monarchy
what did she do to the monarchy will she
let Rupert Murdoch buy the son she made
the that the Sun newspaper The Times
newspaper group so powerful Rupert
Murdoch as you will know is a Republican
he's had absolutely no compunction in
going after the royal family left them
in a situation now where they're on a
par with pop idol what about our armed
forces the importance of our armed
forces listening to the previous
speakers you would think actually that
sir that it was Margaret Thatcher who
ended the cold war rather than Mikhail
Gorbachev can I remind you that it was
Yuri Andropov who put Gorbachev into the
Politburo not Margaret Thatcher
and it was Mikhail Gorbachev himself at
meeting with with Helmut Kohl in 1990
who agreed to the reunification of
Germany and Germany's inclusion in NATO
these were things that the Soviet Union
did for itself and strangely enough
that's I'd say it's ironic I suppose
that Gorbachev had that one thing in
common with Margaret Thatcher that he
was in the end done down by his own
colleagues he wasn't able to complete
his revolution but don't let people
rewrite history and tell you that the
West won the Cold War
democracy won the Cold War the people of
the Soviet Union how fortunate we are
think of all those years during the Cold
War when we feared that it would end in
nuclear holocaust but it actually end
ended in the people of Eastern Europe
rising up and liberating themselves
isn't that a great achievement for
Europe I think that's one of one of the
greatest achievements of the twentieth
century our sovereignty the sovereignty
of our nation which Prime Minister
plugged us more into Europe than
Margaret Thatcher she signed the single
European Act you should listen to what
you keep say under their breath about
Margaret Thatcher on their weird little
websites it's amazing what you can find
out when you put these words into a
search engine Margaret Thatcher signed a
single European Act and her how and
heard all of them pro-european cabinet
members took Britain further and further
closer and closer towards a European
super-state and most crucially though
the damage I think that she did was to
our way of life and to the family by
destroying the trade unions by breaking
the power of the trade unions she left
ordinary working people with no one to
protect themselves from the creeping
Americanization of our workplace and our
culture it's true that there were high
tax rates to the top rate of tax in 1983
when she came to power was 83 percent
it's now 40 percent but up until 1979
inequality in Britain had been
diminishing since 1948
since the setting up of the welfare
state since 1989 inequality has been
widening again in this country it's true
that she did find a country in decline
but that was because we were dealing
literally both psychologically and
economically with the decline of our
Empire that period of time was over and
those problems were exasperated and and
just made much much worse by the the
decision in 1973 of the OPEC nations to
begin to punish the west through hiking
of oil prices yes the Labour government
did go and lend money from the IMF but
when Margaret Thatcher came to power the
things that she did to the British
economy were far beyond anything the IMF
had been demanded and even Milton
Friedman the architect of my tourism at
one point criticized her for creating
unnecessary unemployment she cut taxes
it's true and she cut red red tape in
order to fire inflation the great
monster of the late 60s and the 1970s
but despite this inflation grew and
unemployment went to record levels and
the fractures that she caused in our
society have not yet healed she was an
ideologue she once told you observer
that her way of construction and
government was to have in it only people
who want to go in the direction that the
Prime Minister wants to go to me she
said consensus seems to be a process of
abandoning beliefs principles values and
policies
she later commented that people who
believed in consensus were quislings and
traitors she realized to think that the
only way that she could open Britain to
the corporate greed that's already been
referred to by previous speakers to make
us competitive was to smash the post-war
consensus that had built up at the
experience of the British people during
the Second World War as far as I'm
concerned the great sacrifice of the
British people in the Second World War
was we've rewarded by the setting up in
1948 of the welfare state and the
consensus that built around that between
all political parties that it was
clearly a good idea to have a society in
which there was collective provision of
health
of Education and decent affordable
housing all of these things were
dreadfully undermined by Margaret
Thatcher my point is she was not a
conservative in the classic sense in the
One Nation sense in the sense of Charles
Moore in the sense that Peregrine was on
here believing she was something else
she was an interest
just as the Labour Party was was entered
by socialist Marxist revolutionaries in
the 1970s so the Conservative Party in
the mid-1970s was entered by a
capitalist interest group led by
Margaret Thatcher and putting forward
the ideas of monetarism we might now
call them neoconservatives in the
present language where they believe in
in very few things certainly not facts
they they believe in in greed and they
believe in force and they believe in
their own the righteousness of their own
cause Margaret Thatcher embodied these
principles while George Bush was still
chugging beers and driving around drunk
and doing all those other things he did
before he found the person whose name we
don't want to mention in politics
because those those things don't go
together
my point is that the Margaret Thatcher
Margaret Thatcher left us as her legacy
a spiteful country a nasty country a
country which had forgotten really what
it was about in the end the rights of
the individual are very very important
but they can only be assured by the
collective provision of certain things
health care education decent affordable
housing sure she sold off all the
council houses but where your kid's
gonna live how they going to afford a
house and she did let everybody else
share so now everybody has shares and no
pension in the end it's not either
individualism or collectivism it's a
mixture of the two Margaret Thatcher in
her own way in her own terrible way was
a radical I ask you to vote against this
motion and
[Applause]
goody thanks very much indeed for that
our final speaker for emotion is Sir
John not prominent Conservative MP
during the 70s and 80s he must notably
served a Secretary of State for Defence
in mrs. Thatcher's government during the
Falklands War and before that as
President of the Board of Trade his
autobiography here today gone tomorrow
takes its title from a famous moment
almost 20 years ago and I'll tell you
what it is because I see quite a few
young faces in the audience here who
probably won't remember that instant
during a live primetime interview on BBC
television
Sir Robin day the great Inquisitor
called him and I quote a here today gone
tomorrow politician in response he
called the interview ridiculous pulled
off his lapel microphone and walked off
the set and out of the studio he clearly
is not doing that tonight for which we
are immensely grateful
Sir John no sir Thank You mr. chairman
I had about 800 letters after I walked
out of my interview with Robin day and
only three disapproved and they all came
from the BBC but I want to start by
saying that Billy who spoke before me is
unquestionably a national treasure and
he shares that distinction with Margaret
Thatcher
it's it's it's some absolutely true that
Margaret Thatcher was not a conservative
in the traditional meaning of that word
unlike Billy he's old labor conservative
Margaret was a radical and the times if
some people here will remember them
required a radical and that's what they
got and I look to see how many people
voted for Margaret Thatcher in 1979 it
was thirteen point seven million and in
83 it was exactly the same number 13
million voted for Margaret Thatcher and
after eight years the number of people
who voted for her at the British general
election had risen so if all the things
that are said about her and some of them
are not really very nice or fair are
true why did the British people go on
voting for her and why all these votes
where did they come from
of course they came mainly from
traditional labour voters now Billy I
have a great admiration for him and I
took the great advantage of buying his
biography it cook it it it it caught it
yes no it's not it's been remaindered
and
it did in fact cost me a pound and Perry
Perry's book by the way is 2 pounds off
I'm afraid if you buy my book which I'm
sure you all will it you'll have to pay
the full price
now Billy I want to say he did a great
job
during those thatcher years at community
sing songs all around the country they
all gathered round and sang the red flag
it must have been a really fun evening
ah but the the the the one that I like
most of all most of all was he did the
saving school dinners thing and he sang
a thing called don't let spam fritters
become a thing of the past now I like
that very much because spam fritters are
an authentic socialist dish Nigella
Lawson please note now why did all those
natural labour supporters vote for the
Tories in 59 in 79 and 83 it was because
a gang of trade union leaders had
grabbed political power they were
sapping the power of the government to
govern and of business to succeed I
remember most Evans Rae bucked and Jack
Jones Scanlon Mick maga he getting
indigestion by continually eating
sandwiches at number 10 bodies were
lying unburied in the mortuary as
rubbish was piling up in the streets
food and fuel supplies were disrupted
schools were closed for want of heating
and in 1978 I think Charles mentioned
this 25 million working days have been
lost with strikes some people might say
it was a real socialist paradise Great
Britain was the sick man of Europe and
everybody laughed at us the whole
post-war establishment senior
politicians and civil servants in this
country were presiding over what I think
Charles described as the politics of
decline the sick man of Europe the
established British
to establish some thought should be
allowed to decline peacefully in a
gentlemanly fashion in the sort of way
that Perry would approve of without
confrontation the workers the CBI and
even Perry's Arastoo Kratz in defense of
aristocracy his book they were all
combined together to make sure that
nothing was ruffled that this country
declined peacefully now the fact is that
Margaret was a radical and aristocratic
paternalism had actually failed Harold
Macmillan was a great paternalist and
one can understand that someone who
fought in the First World War in the
trenches with the soldiers who had these
Whiggish connections as a result of his
marriage who'd actually had a
constituency in the north of England in
pre-war days one can understand why he
felt as he did but he did preside Harold
Macmillan over the National Committee
for the peaceful acceptance of national
decline and a group of Tory radicals led
by Margaret Thatcher decided things had
to change
now Ted Heath actually and I was in his
government made a valiant attempt to do
a deal with the Wreckers so we had
something called try part ISM a sort of
cosy deal between the government the
unions in the CBI and Ted did try he had
an appalling horror of unemployment and
it led actually tripart ISM the deal
that he tried to make to chaos and so
what happened was the Tory party was
disrupted Julian Critchley called it the
peasants revolt the back benches of the
Tories party rose up in rebellion and
they booted out Ted Heath and replaced
him with Margaret Thatcher a rather
strident lady and in perry's words in
his book he says we were replacing an
existing lot of tolerance and genial
rulers but
cause established and secure I agree
with that
with a lot of almost certainly insecure
and roughed edge rulers because new and
unestablished that's Jeff's like us new
and unestablished we were out of East's
and second-hand car dealers from Essex
we were called garage East's garage
East's people were advised to write to
Margaret Thatcher care of Dickens and
Jones now many people here I don't know
if Dickens and Jones still exists I
think it almost certainly does not so
it's a straight quote from your book
Perry sorry well never mind we'll find
it for you afterwards now I can
understand some people's hostility
towards something called Thatcherism you
know I never heard a conservative refer
to Thatcherism it was a word invented by
the left as a term of abuse but Margaret
Thatcher certainly believed in
self-interest but self-interest is
different from selfishness and
selfishness is different from greed no
politics comes in concede in a democracy
if it is not based on self-interest for
individuals and for families the task is
to channel self-interest into promoting
the public good so I conclude by saying
that Margaret Thatcher's greatest
achievement in my view was to arrest and
reverse the politics of decline it
needed her as a courageous and tough
leader with a group of other people
around her to boot the British
establishment out of its lethargy
and yes institutions had to be
confronted yes the country had to be
jerked out of the complacency that had
lasted far too long since the Second
World War the political power of the
trains unions was destroyed not the
trades unions the trade unions weren't
destroyed their political power was
destroyed the sale of council houses
gave ordinary families a sense of
personal independence and ownership
zatia destroyed the cozy and utterly
uninterpreted the public sector
it was painful very painful but the old
declining industries had to be closed
down if you were to tell a young
audience today
that before privatisation of British
Telecom that's not very long ago it took
you six months to get a telephone and
then it only came in black they wouldn't
believe you
that's what privatization did of course
it is true that the collapse of the
steel coal shipbuilding in other state
industries was unbearably painful and
the high price of the pound exacerbated
unemployment but the country had to be
forced into the real world there was
never going to be any game without pain
and the final act actually which opened
this country to the real world was the
abolition of exchange controls I
remember I was a Treasury Minister and
one of my Jobs was to police exchange
control and a lot of PC plods retired
policemen used to come into my office
and a great gang of people from the Bank
of England and they used to show me a
brochure of holiday villas which were
owned in Spain and elsewhere and they
said that these people have bought their
villas overseas without going through
what was known as the premium dollar you
had to pay a big premium in order to buy
anything abroad it was the kind of
closed world so beloved of totalitarian
states it was a nanny estate now no one
loves the sick man of Europe anymore we
have higher growth and lower
unemployment than any of our European
partners I have a chart at home which
shows the wealth of France and the
wealth of England over the last 200
years and it's only actually during the
last few years that this country has
become richer than France and in fact we
are now the fourth richest country in
the world now economics is
dismal science and I don't by any means
suggest that prosperity is more
important than social cohesion and
happiness but my goodness prosperity
counts and history shows that when a
country travels towards economic
collapse and hanneke which is exactly
the position we were in in 79 that is
the thing that brings around a
totalitarian state so I conclude by
saying that in my view Maggie Thatcher
did save Britain and I don't see really
how anyone can deny that fact thank you
so John thank you our final speaker
opposing the motion is Diane Abbott who
is one of that rare breed these days an
independent-minded and feisty Member of
Parliament she made history by becoming
the first black woman ever elected to
the British Parliament and a since built
a distinguished career as a
parliamentarian broadcaster and
commentator she served on a number of
parliamentary committees she's been on
the Treasury select committee the
Foreign Affairs Select Committee and
most recently she has set up a special
parliamentary committee investigating
gun crime she appears regularly on
television and radio who would miss a
regular appearances on Andrew Neal's
late-night political discussion
programme on BBC one where she just with
Michael Portillo but when I say that she
set up a special parliamentary committee
investigating gun crime I am convinced
that she has come here tonight armed
only with words with which to oppose the
motion it is with some trepidation that
I come to the rostrum this evening
following an array of clever
distinguished and mostly titled
gentlemen to put forward the proposition
in front of the Sarat ranks of middle
England that the Thatcher era was not in
fact a golden age and I am mindful of
the immensity of my task after all some
of you are too young to remember the 70s
and so will believe all that guff from
Tim Bell about dead bodies piled in the
streets and all the rest some of you may
have done well under Thatcherism and
some of you even might secretly believe
like my friends the Peregrine that the
only problem with mrs. Thatcher was that
she was really a little bit too
bourgeois but nonetheless despite the
immensity of my task
I have arguments to put before you even
though I'm well aware that if you're
talking about mrs. Thatcher saving
Britain in many ways I'm exactly the
sort of person she was supposed to saved
Britain from
[Applause]
let me begin by making one point you've
heard speaker after speaker mostly
titled come to the rostrum and trash the
post-1945 welfare state they would have
you believe that from the 1945 general
election and the election of the Acme
government to 1979 nothing good happened
Britain was a basket case it was one
long litany of decline and as more than
one of them are said piles of dead
bodies lay in the streets let me tell
you something about the post 1945
well first day because it's fashionable
even I have to say among some of my
colleagues in New Labour to trash it let
me tell you I am a product of the 1945
welfare said I was born in 1953 and only
under that dispensation could the child
of Jamaican immigrants who themselves
left school at 14 come here and have I
say it without new modesty really one of
the best education money could buy all
the way through to New College Cambridge
and a master's degree in history for
free and leave that University believing
that I was as good as the Lord not the
certain bells and the Charles more free
orange juice
free education and a sense of equality
those were some of the themes of the
post 1945 welfare state and you've heard
a lot about politics tonight from
Westminster insiders but let me tell you
for ordinary British people when they
look back on that period from 1945 to
1970 many of the things that are most
intrinsically British many of the things
we are proudest of many of the things
which mark our British identity whether
we originate from Jamaica Pakistan or
right here in Britain many of those
things flourished
and characterize the post-1945 area it
suits the saturates to say nothing good
happened it suits the Thatcherite
to to create this calf caress nightmare
nightmare picture but it wasn't the
reality for my generation I entered
Parliament in 1987 and mrs. Thatcher was
then in all her pomp and pride and let
me agree with some of the speakers that
have spoken before me and say she was a
truly remarkable person no question
about it I unlike anyone else on this
son platform sat opposite her in
Parliament on the opposing benches for
years and years and perhaps the most
extraordinary thing about mrs. Thatcher
was there was this some lady you know
for teas I think she must have been when
I first crossed her path surrounded by
an almost entirely male Conservative
Party much warmer than yesterday and she
would sit there on her front bench our
ankles much admired by people like Sir
Timberland Lord not as a child her her
ankles very neatly crossed and each and
every one of those August nights of the
Shires
and Tory MPs in suits were scared
shitless of them and that was truly
remarkable that it was worth being an MP
in the nineteen eighties to go into the
house and contemplate that spectacle day
after day after because she knew many of
them despised her because she was after
all a grocer's daughter
you knew made them didn't know how they
ended up with woman as leader in the
first place and yet she ruled them
entirely through fear and you will have
seen in the speeches we've heard this
evening that mrs. Thatcher to this day
excites a strange mix of idolatry and
fear in a certain sort of Englishman not
being English by background and not
being a man I dare inspect latest what
it is
memories of a bear bottom being spanked
by nanny I won't go down that path but
what I'm asking you to do for the
remaining minutes of my remarks is to
strip away the misty
to strip away the glamorization and mrs.
Thatcher by the Lord knots and the
certain bells and the Sir Charles Moors
and to look I'm sorry not such a smile
but it suits him doesn't it just strip
away all of that idolatry and strip away
the way they rewrote history rewrote
trashed everything that happened for 30
years until she came to power and to
look at the social consequences of
Thatcherism because if you look at
Vassar ISM and society if you look at
Vassar ISM and domestic policy her
leading idea her big idea the idea which
for better or worse New Labour continues
to implement was the elevation of the
market for mrs. Thatcher the market
always knew best for mrs. Thatcher there
was no form of social provision being
education be it health be it care for
the elderly which would not be improved
by the introduction of market forces and
yes that did represent a break with what
is described as the but Scalia consensus
the consensus which ruled from 45 to
1917 she did attempt to take the market
and market forces where market forces
hadn't been before and we are living
with mrs. Thatcher's elevation of the
market mrs. Thatcher's big idea mrs.
Thatcher's deification of market forces
to this day last night my government my
own government put forward legislation
to deregulate casinos as if the people
in Hackney are short of places to gamble
as this as this the introduction of huge
US casino monopolies onto British soil
represents any sort of gain the society
as a whole but that is where saturate
deification of the market takes you and
when the people say that miss
such a saved Britain when the Lord knots
and the certain bells of the Charles
Moore say that she saved Britain they
mean she saved their Britain I put it to
you that there's a wider Britain outside
the Westminster village and a wider
reality who are perhaps not so quick to
believe that she saved them
did she save the elderly it was mrs.
Thatcher that broke the link between
pensions and earnings and what we've had
ever since her era is the relative
decline of the state pension until now
we have one of the lowest pensions in
Europe of course because she adored the
market so much she also told the elderly
or people approaching old age or you can
put your money into private pensions
which of course collapse did she save
young people she brought the market into
education she began the move to take
away grants did she save the poor when
mrs. Thatcher left office we were in a
more divided society than ever a bigger
gap between rich and poor than ever but
finally let me say this mrs. Thatcher
left us free proud and successful free
if you know a person struggling to live
on a declining pension what are we proud
of the hundreds and hundreds of homeless
people you can see in the centre of
London any evening this week successful
if you judge success as Charles Moore
does by your rate of tax maybe she was a
success but I believe and I'm in politic
because I believe that there are many
other important things to building a
good society I believe that mrs.
Thatcher may have saved Britain for the
people represented on this top table but
I believe we are living with the
damaging consequences of a deification
of the market to this day I beg you to
oppose the motion
[Music]
dan thank you very much indeed for that
and just before we allow you the
audience to enter the fray I can tell
you how you voted when you came in today
347 of you were for the motion and 142
you were against 157 of you did not know
so 157 minds to be to be made up and I
have to say that if all those minds were
made up to join those against the motion
the motion would still be carried unless
some of the 347 who came in here voting
for it have decided that they will
change their minds in the view of what
they have heard tonight and that's what
makes what happens in the next few
minutes particularly exciting so who
would like to kick off the one proviso I
would make by the way is that please
keep your comments relatively short so
that as many people as possible can have
a say you can either ask a question or
you can make a comment if you want to
direct it to a member of the panel
please do so I won't call in every
member of the panel on every question
and we will try and rock and roll
through this as quickly as we can
editing as we go as it were and I see a
question from I think it's the lady down
there at the back with a hand up if you
could get a microphone there and if
you'd like to just tell us give us your
name and maybe who you represent so the
evidence can be taken down and used
against you thank you okay can you hear
me my name is Victoria Preston and I'm a
lifelong labour voter but I'm very very
disillusioned with dynabox government do
you think Diane that Martin Lewis was
right when he said that Margaret
Thatcher's save Britain because she made
Tony Blair possible or that she didn't
save Britain because she made Tony bear
possible and that was that was intended
as a little joke at the beginning but
someone's taking it
someone's taking it very seriously how
would how would you interpret it did did
Margaret Thatcher make Tony Blair
possible um there are many remarkable
things about Tony Blair but I did I did
ask you to keep your answers short but
when it comes to domestic policy I would
argue this is a problem some of us in a
party have with him but he's actually
mrs. Thatcher's natural son and heir a
much of what he's done is to bed down
many of the turns to the market which
she took in the eighties so so so mrs.
Thatcher did change Witten well as far
as Tony Blair's concerned I mean partly
you went to her for advice in the early
days of his Premiership and you see what
happened
right next uh next question please yes
general down here yes you could stand up
everybody that would be great yep um so
General John Maddox sex editor of nature
I would i voted on the way in to oppose
this motion and nothing i've heard this
is this evening has changed my mind and
the reason for it is quite specific
quite specific to mrs. Thatcher if you
look at the proportion of British GDP
gross domestic product spent on research
in Britain you find that it was quite
high in the 1940s just under two percent
it fell steadily from 1984 to 1997 it's
now going back up again thanks to the
Liberal government's policies mrs.
Thatcher was responsible for this it
happened on her watch as Donald Rumsfeld
could say and little it in my spell of
nature I went to see her trading on the
fact that you and I have been trained in
chemistry in the same lab at the same
time although I must say she was much
busier running for chairman of the
Oxford University Conservative Party
Burnham for chemistry nevertheless I
went to see her and asked her why
British spending on research had
declined and she had the goal to say the
following these international
comparisons don't matter
because after all as you know but his
scientists are smarter and that struck
me at the time to be an ignorant remark
I did my best to suggest so but also one
that was deeply damaging to button
so John it's such a complicated subject
I mean I would like to know how you
define research are you talking about
public sector funded research or private
sector research are you talking about
original research or applied research or
I mean you know it's a huge subject so I
couldn't really respond without knowing
what you're referring to well well I
think let's I think that is a subject
for another debate actually I think we
won't we won't pursue that at the moment
if you don't mind but thank you very
much for making that point yes gentlemen
just down there yeah thank you and
anyone is there anyone up in the good
juice if you'd like to join the queue
for the microphone up there if you want
to speak just make your way around to
the microphone I'll see you're up there
and come to you and I'll come to you
could we get a microphone to this lady
here and we'll come to her after it
after we've taken that lady up thank you
Tony cousin price entrepreneur I'd like
to ask the panel and particularly the
for about to remind them and asked them
about Tina and I think Tina was sorry it
was at the time the reason a lot of us
thought that supported Thatcher there is
no alternative and I think that the
panel has implied four of the panel the
four panel has implied there was no
alternative 25 years of hindsight it
seems to me that one can no longer say
there was no up no alternative you can
look at continental Europe and you can
see economies that are just as healthy
as ours and you can see policies which
are much healthier than ours that it was
an alternative and I'm glad to see that
Dodd fell to one of the temptations
which I think all Thatcher files have to
fall to which is to cling to onto any
statistic which shows that continental
Europe is doing less well than we are
Thatcher files have been trying to do
this for 20 years and statistic after
statistic shows that they do not they're
doing just as well and they did not
destroy their policies okay
was there an alternative Bell sorry I
don't know if you remember who invented
Tina I've heard it said about Blair I've
heard it said about many things and I've
actually heard this government talk a
great deal about how much better Britain
performs than the rest of Europe so I
don't think that is exclusive here the
territory of people you can fetch her
files nor do I think your arguments very
compelling we didn't set out the
Thatcher government didn't set out to
try and beat Europe the Thatcher
government set out to try and change the
direction that this country was heading
this country was going down the tubes
and she did the things that were
necessary to stop it going down the
tubes and make it believe in itself
again and enable it to be a success
that's what the debate is about you
don't like her that's entirely your
affair a lot of people don't and the
gentleman before you doesn't like her
attitude towards research and nobody
suggested that people I don't think she
didn't call was popularity which is one
of the things I admired about her is
that what you saying Tim basically I
mean this whole idea this whole idea
that we weren't in some way competing
with you I think was you who used the
phrase of sick man in Europe when you
spoke I mean it is true I mean it's
always Germany that we're compared to
presently that we're so much better off
than Germans that's because they've had
to take an industrially wrecked country
into their economy over the last 10 15
years it's gonna take them a long time
before they survive that we're still
working to get I walk was done during
the 18 years of Thatcherism it's going
to take us a long time to put our policy
back together as well okay Chuck Charles
would you want to come in on that point
of Germany's troubles at the moment or
maybe specifically do as Billy suggests
to the to the reunification well they
clearly they clearly are added to by
reunification but I think they are more
profound I think there was no
alternative because our situation
in economic and industrial relation
terms was so much worse when mrs.
Thatcher became Prime Minister than was
the case in Germany or France and what
you're seeing now is
a need to confront comparable problems
not so severe but comparable in Germany
and France and other continental
countries which they have very poor
political means of dealing with because
they for a understandable historical
reasons are very very frightened of the
conflict that is involved in dealing
with these questions but unfortunately
conflict is sometimes involved in
dealing with this question so this was
the key factor in sight and when people
talk about her fracturing society
unnecessarily but do think is very very
important remember that it was fractured
it was broken and somebody had to fix it
Jim Callahan when he was prime minister
in his last year was in virtually in
tears I think actually wasn't tears
about the behavior of the trade union
movement that he loved he thought the
sheer selfishness that word has been
used a lot she agreed that was exhibited
by union leaders was beyond his
comprehension he didn't know what to do
about his attempt to work with them had
failed and something different had to
come and he did so it's a Paragon how do
you react to to Charles point that
there's an element of conflict involved
in in achieving any kind of effective
change please I can't I couldn't hear so
I don't feel I really that that was that
was the point one of the points he was
making that in fact you have to have a
degree of conflict which mrs. Thatcher
was was rather good at in order to in
order to achieve effective change well I
think that's a truism that that nobody
could deny but I think there's an equal
truism do you have to have a measure of
consensus if you're gonna hold a society
together I think we can swap truisms and
ruling and the cows come home without
getting very much better in the argument
okay Donna you say that Lord nots made a
very telling and I might say so about
Thatcherite point that you have no gain
without pain
[Laughter]
he made he made an important point about
such right point when you said that
there's no gain without pain the problem
for some of us about the Thatcherite
years is that Thatcherite made all the
game and the rest of us had to endure
all the pain there was an alternative of
course there was there was an
alternative and that was to proceed in
the way that the Macmillan and indeed
the Heath government had attempted to
bring about consensus but everybody who
lived through that period realizes that
at the end of the Heath government
consensus had broken down and failed so
there was an alternative but it just
didn't work there was no alternative to
mrs. Thatcher's determination to to
reduce the power of the trade unions
that was what she will be remembered for
doing but she didn't risk there did she
she went to do the same thing to the
professions she tried to do the churches
she tried to do it to the universities
nobody really questions that the was
that the trade unions were causing a
great deal of economic disastrous
trouble but surely we can agree there
but then the really interesting question
is the second stage the the march
through the professions and through the
institutions that is the thing which
endangered and still endangered the
health of this society and that is the
central it seems to me indictment not
about the trade unions really but about
the forces we unleashed in beating the
trade unions which swept through the
rest of society with grave damage Ruth
we are suffering from to this day that
is what I would beg of you
to remember not that the we nobody can
argue about that she had to take on mr.
Scargill but what happened afterwards
the region good night it could I take a
quick series of points from the floor
this lady here who has the microphone
and after that the gentleman by the
pillar by the pillar there who's raising
his hand and then and then and then
we'll take we'll take two from up above
thanking yes this lady Charlotte Leslie
Kensington Chelsea Conservatives if
Margaret Thatcher did or didn't save
Britain was exactly apart from Diane did
or didn't she save Britain from and can
ask the panel what their ideas of
success at that juncture in time would
have been and whether various forms of
success would be mutually exclusive I
yep okay Tim products of decline which I
think we've all tried to explain in our
own ways Diane's irritation which
actually wasn't an attack on every
government since 1945 it was a comment
so I beg your fun I'll start again what
she saved his promise the politics of
decline and the acceptance that Britain
should become a second division country
wallowing in a rather genteel desperate
situation definitions of success I think
that winning the Cold War was successful
whether Diane thinks we wanted it or not
I think we don't believe all I think we
did win it
I think getting Britain to a point where
it is competitive in the in the world is
important I think that the British
people feeling keen on themselves is
important I think those are examples of
success and as I said very beginning the
alternative that hung around at the time
that she came to office was to continue
down the path of decline or stop that
decline and run back up the down
escalators first week ago and that's
what she did right let me let me take a
question from up in that up in the
guards yes Richard Hart on a
conservative
question library I'm slightly alarmed by
the fact you've got a full scab page in
front of you a couple of quick sentences
and think because of what I want to do
now is try to just Hoover up some some
thoughts and opinions and questions
which are panelist can then incorporate
in their remarks at the end do you do
the panelists consider that we could
have achieved their commit prosperity we
have them from the search for error with
a little less of the breakdown in social
cohesion I think that could have been
possible if things have been done
differently right thank you let's let's
let's let let's park that for the moment
yes the gentleman up at the back by the
pillar and then could you get a
microphone to this gentleman just down
here you'd raise your hand well good
evening ladies and gentlemen my name is
Simon Daris I'm a lifelong conservative
Diane Abbott like mistress in the hall I
hope like mysteries in the country one
day I hope Diane Abbott made great clay
of this web deification is a mrs.
Thatcher was in the habit of burning
incense before an image called marketeer
or something in the depths of Darling
Street I would put it down a buret that
she and her political warfare certainly
before the fall of the Soviet Union
certainly before the discrediting of
socialist tyranny throughout the world
made a god of the state and the only
thing that can provide pensions other
than the market is the state and very
unpleasant poor little pensions they
usually are too if you look at France
it's facing a terrible deficit precisely
because it tries to provide pensions on
the on those lines and if you look back
England mrs. Thatcher had successfully
transferred pensions to the private
section still the Wreckers Gordon Brown
decided to take five billion from the
pension funds every year and pushed the
stock market down so again it is
socialism failure
it was capitalism success I trust it
will be capitalism success once again
let me take yes this gentleman here my
name is Neville Conrad mr. chairman I've
attended these debates right from the
outset and I think mr. Waldman
and I'm bound to say that without any
doubt the contribution that I heard from
severa Grimm was one of the finest
contributions I've heard in any debate
here on any subject and I would ask I
would ask members of the committee of
the audience when considering voting to
think very carefully about what he said
of course Margaret Thatcher um put an
oxygen mask and on business and on
enterprise and of course she got the
dustbins of the street but what else did
she do she created mini capitalists by
the very interesting ways of bringing
home ownership into everybody's reach
but she also created a society that
unless you owned then you weren't
counted now did Margaret Thatcher save
Britain what is Britain it's a state
it's a society now what one must ask
oneself when deciding whether she's say
Britain did she really save society or
his society in the state it's in today
because of her
jaren right I just want to end by by
coincidence I came across a piece by
Matthew Parris in which I couldn't
believe
reading that he quoted our birth fascist
a a man who be only 26 who finds himself
on a bus he kept himself a failure and I
put that to view if you really believe
she said that you cannot vote for the
motion
yes can I take the lady the lady up
sorry gentlemen sorry Biggers I'm sorry
Craig Rimmer conservative as well I
other any labor supporters in here can I
do there are yes okay okay very quickly
because I do want to take some some
points of view than the other side of
the argument if we could get microphones
to that gentleman there with the with
the fuzzy hair yeah I just I just want
to touch on the language issue about
discordant language obviously Margaret
Thatcher started off with a speech
outside number 10 I said you know
creating some francis of assisi s and
and talking about bringing a chord and
and all of that and channel of my piece
and all that sort of stuff but with I
mean so sir Peregrine was talking about
language and had been discordant and
Margaret Thatcher was almost waging a
war with language but who actually felt
they were being attacked by the language
of those 13 million voters as we hear
who were constantly coming out voting
for Margaret Thatcher she employed
language that FDR even used in the
United States of creating mysterious
enemies in many ways to attack to
actually unite the nation behind her and
the party and the government to go on
and fight the real enemies in terms of
the bankruptcy of this country at that
time she she did what was needed in that
respect and now I noticed I noticed even
Diane is into this sort of discordant
language creating the mysterious enemies
when she talks about Lord Bell Sir
Charles Moore who's been given an
honorary knighthood by Diane and Sir
John not this was her attempt at
discordant language thank you okay fine
thank you and the was there was someone
down there was actually can I take yes
sorry there we are yes the person there
with the with a splendid fuzzy hair
thank you can you hear me okay I am a
Labour Party member and a supporter
and actually to a certain degree I have
Margaret Thatcher to thank because of
her disastrous policy I joined the
Labour Party and actually become a very
stout parliamentarian as well so I
remember the time during Patrick years
when Holmes although she sold them off
actually she didn't invest in rebuilds
so a lot of people became homeless and
there was a huge waiting list for
council properties really targeting the
poor and the disadvantaged in our
communities so in a sense perhaps she
did say Britain but who did she save it
for certainly not for the disadvantaged
of those people who represented the
working classes I remember the bankrupt
businesses in the huge numbers that did
go into bankruptcy and into liquidation
I remember those
homeowners who've had their homes for
years and who were repossessed and I
suspect the panel four are actually
probably like a pregnant woman who
forgets the painter and labor and
promptly goes and has another baby
afterwards so perhaps the panel for the
four should really read rest its
policies and its perspective certainly
Thatcher was right for you because you
gained on the Thatcher reserve but not
for the majority of the working classes
and certainly not with a majority of the
British people thank you
can I take the gentlemen just down there
in the blue in the I think it's a light
blue shirt gentleman there and then I'll
take one more person from upstairs yeah
is there any chance of Sir John not
returning to the front bench of the
tourist party because we need we need
people with common sense and he has a
good understanding of economics you
would do well to spend some time
learning some basic economics from men
like him
[Applause]
Alice showed not a member of any
political party I gathered oh good
heavens that's amazing how did you get
in through the back door I gather that
over the period of time in question the
poor have got poorer and the rich have
got richer if that is the case would the
panel tell us in what sense Maggie
Thatcher could have been said to have
saved the poor of Britain there may be a
sense so what has Maggie Thatcher done
to save that section that got poorer
that is a very good thought to to leave
with our panel in fact we have now come
to the to the if you like the final five
six minutes because I'm conscious of the
fact that we do want to try to end as we
promised everyone at a thirty although I
guess we could have gone on all evening
I'm going to ask each of our panelists
in reverse order for a one-minute
summing up and while they're doing that
would you like to cast your votes with
your tickets which you've got right now
if you want to vote for against tear
them in half and drop the appropriate
the appropriate word into the box if you
want to abstain just drop in the ticket
unn torn into the box and we're going to
do that now as is our tradition while
the panelists while the panelists are
summing up and and then we will give you
the result of that when they have
finished there's something up I know
it's slightly unconventional but it's
something that we do do here and it
keeps interest bubbling right through
until the end so so can I first of all
ask our panelists strictly one quick
minute each while all of you are voting
dan would you like to would you like to
start and give us a quick quick minute
this whether or not you believe that
mrs. Thatcher say Britain depends on
your perspective depends on whether you
gain from that area era or whether you
would dis benefit it and I would put it
to the audience even at this late stage
that there is a wider Britain outside
this hall
who are living with the social
consequences and the thatch Arian for
them she didn't actually save anything
that they held in Sir John well I spend
my whole time on a bus and I didn't know
I was never frightened of Margaret
Thatcher and if anyone had been in the
cabinet meetings that I was in they
would have been astonished at the heat
an argument that was creating I've never
understood this statement that some she
ruled by fear
she loved argument she loved dispute and
it puzzles me anyhow as I say I always
travel on a bus because mister
livingstone has given me a bus pass and
I don't really see why the council tax
payers in Hackney should be paying for
my travel so perhaps the market would be
better able to redistribute wealth and
resources rather mr. Livingstone and
finally I just say that I remember going
to Gatwick years ago before Margaret
Thatcher came into power I can tell you
you didn't see huge millions and
millions of people taking their Ronel or
easy jet flights to Spain I mean the
prosperity of the country has been
transformed no one is suggesting the
prosperity is everything and there may
be a lack of social cohesion at the
moment and we must try and recapture it
but Margaret Thatcher didn't destroy the
health service she tried to improve it
didn't destroy it she didn't destroy the
trade unions she's trying to take away
their political power she didn't destroy
education she actually tried to improve
it
I'm not sure she was always successful
in those objectives but um the notion
that she was hard-nosed
and I'm thinking about social cohesion
and social think it's just simply untrue
in my view Billy Bragg thank you yes
what I'm greatly encouraged by the
turnout tonight that this is still a
matter of some some dispute I get a
little warm glow in my heart every time
when I'm watching question time and her
name gets mentioned and the audience
hits it it cheers me up greatly one of
the reasons why we don't want the Labour
government to legislate for the building
of mega casinos is because we are
concerned about people when they gamble
we think they're wasting their money
it's going to impoverish them well
Margaret Thatcher did in order to make
those 13 million people vote for them
was she allowed them to gamble she
allowed them to gamble because what she
used to reverse the decline in this
country as the guy was asking up there
was she used market forces and in
unleashing market force market forces
those thirty million people took a
gamble that they might benefit from it
my sense is the majority of them did not
one of the great things that she
achieved I think is to put the
Conservative Party in a position where
someone as ordinary straightforward
straight talk and as Michael Portillo
can't even find a CE that's Margaret
Thatcher's legacy she did that to
conservatives we have that to thank her
for in the end the point is in the end I
think Margaret Thatcher won the key
things of perhaps Charles you might want
to think about this for your tongue is
the thing that's significant about
Margaret Thatcher was she was the last
prime minister to be born before the
welfare state came in to be born not in
the 1940s as subsequent prime ministers
and leaders have been but to be born in
1925 she had a sensibility that was pre
welfare state she saw it as something
that was undermining those values and
her entire career was devoted to trying
to bring that down because in the end
whether she likes it or not
there is such a thing as society and if
you take out the institutions that
support society then the whole damn
thing is going to crumble around your
ears
Lord Bell well I think that's quite
interesting actually I think but in
order to make your mind up how you're
going to vote you need to think about
this it's quite obvious that Billy and
Diane think that the market is the cause
of all disaster and misery and
unhappiness and they identify Margaret
as being the market which of course
she's and she was indeed keen on the
market and what what you've got is three
different views expressed you hear those
of us who believe in small citizens in
large citizens and small states who
believe in individual responsibility you
believe that allowing people to grow and
succeed is a good thing those people who
believe that people should be dependent
on the state that the state knows how
people should live their lives and how
they should spend their money more
dictate them out of do it and then
you've got the rather grand view that
Perry has which is whichever way you
choose it please do eloquently and I the
reality is that the attitude of the
attitude of the state controlling
people's lives started in in in a big
way proposed to war in that this
government it predominated throughout
that period and it got us to the
economic decline that we were in in 1979
and you may not any of all of you
remember what that was like the truth is
that we had gone to the bank manager
because we were broke and we had to
borrow some money in order to get by
they were no way of paying the money
back if we continued to create less
wealth and if we continued simply invest
money in failing services what Margaret
did was save Britain from itself and
absolutely saved Britain from the kind
of economic and social thing in that
Diana but hasn't it very represents that
she didn't save it from the kind of
attitude that the Peregrine has to put
towards these issues that she rather
fond of aristocrats and clearly as Diana
finds it so deeply offensive she'd
managed to crater viewers so that we did
we could continue to be equally grand
and it might just amuse her to know that
I got a knighthood from Margaret
Thatcher and a peerage from Tony Blair
so I must be really really evil
[Applause]
[Music]
sir Peregrine I think see the point
perhaps none of us have mentioned is
they used to be a time when the Brist
and the brightest in this country wanted
to go into public life to make history
and now I think the best and the
brightest much prefer to go into
business and make money now I entirely
agree that you've got to bet the balance
right the balance between those who want
to serve their country and those who
want to feather their own nest because
feathering their own nests cumulatively
feathers feathers it is economically
desirable for all of us but I think we
have now a serious problem which to some
extent I blame mrs. Thatcher for
creating and that is that public life is
no longer attracting anybody nobody
worthwhile wants to go into politics
nobody one worthwhile wants to go into
public life at any level and if this is
the if this is true this is a terrible
terrible indictment of those who are
responsible for bringing this deplorable
state of affairs about do not believe
that the speakers who point to the
statistics of economic growth and say
that is the test of saving Britain if
you have trashed the institution's
Parliament is no longer respected the
civil service is no longer respected all
those who run our institutions are
suspected of being in it on the make
this is a the nation will not benefit
from a public life that has been reduced
to this low esteem and I think that it
is a serious matter to ponder if mrs.
Thatcher did have this consequence all
the stuff we have heard how will the
countries
doing this is something which has to be
regarded in my view as a short-term gain
at a long-term calamity in if our public
life has gone rotten
that is the calamity from which you and
your children will all in the end suffer
[Music]
Charles my final word I think what super
green and Dame Diane and the and what
Martin didn't quite call the barking
Bard
are missing something very very
important there's a novelist not so much
read as he should be called William
Cooper and he in one of his novels has a
distinction he says labour stands for
envy and hope and the Tories stand for
nostalgia and fear and on the whole he
or the character in the book prefers
envy and hope but actually I think what
mrs. Thatcher did is scooped the pool
possibly with all four of them though
conceivably not with envy she had
nostalgia and fear under her belt but
what the other side of missing this is
that she offered hope she offered the
possibility as Labour did in 1945 which
is why working people voted so
overwhelmingly Labour in 1945 the upper
working class in Britain in 1979 and in
83 and in 87 voted for hope they voted
for her because they thought it would
give more opportunity more freedom more
dignity and I think they were right and
that is a very important you have to
remember who this constantly raised who
gains and I think it's not true to say
that the people who were all right
anyway gained it is a whole new set of
people
the rising striving class in society who
gained and that must always be a healthy
thing for society
[Applause]
[Music]
before I before I open this magic piece
of paper to show how your votes have
changed if at all I would like to I'm
also conscious of the fact that you were
going off to look at the result of u.s.
election so I would just like to remind
you a story about a senator who ran for
the presidency about 40 years ago and he
stood in 21 primaries and came bottom
with a poll in every single one and at
the end of the twenty first primary he
called his campaign staff together and
he said he said I'd like to thank you
for supporting me through these
primaries he said but I've decided to
quit the race for the presidency the
people have spoken
the bastards not only is there one
American presidential candidate is going
to be feeling that or maybe maybe he
should be saying the lawyers have spoken
the bastards you know if it gets very
close but not only that but I I feel
that someone three people are possibly
going to be feeling the same way about
you although seriously I suspect not I
think this is has been a very excellent
and charitable debate carried out in
extremely good spirit with some quite
exceptional arguments put forward and
put forward most cogently and well so
how have you voted right at the
beginning 347 of you were for the motion
at the end 393 of you we're for the
motion against was 142 that is now 209
the note don't knows have been reduced
by 48 to 48 from 157 so a hundred people
who came in hundreds of people who came
in here undecided have actually voted
one way or the other and I can tell you
then that that the eyes habits you have
voted by 393 votes to 209 that Maggie
Thatcher did save Britain so thanks to
all of you for your contributions and
raqqa
you